si vous attendez vous j'ai certainement
fait cela c'est devant ce qu'ils se
dépêchent des pneus d'été
à vous d'avoir des seins marché rim
tiens regarde quelque chose pour toi je
te laisse découvrir
non c'est la 205 cité oui ça finit notre
enfant chéri samba remind et espoirs va
être autant là je suis très content de
son jeu voit que t'es trop contente pour
ça
[Musique]
un petit bouton film un temps faut que
j'aille travailler joueurs peuvent ainsi
laisser aller à ce changement ce soir ce
soir
ouais
m
ce d'or il semble
en parlant week-end ça vous dit de venir
chez moi c'est pas mal ça serait du coes
comprend la palme d'or
ces gens là
un personnel d'orange farm en a assez
qu'on parle comme ça va avec
détente exactement s'ils viennent de
jouer pendant partage pas le niveau leur
bac brun lennon c'est un problème
judas corps en passant
mais pour
à pleurer ramallah
121 stations cinéma
on
[Musique]
alors
mais paulo pombolo casser le rêve
je vais bien ça va être chantées urgente
et attend sa création
[Musique]
départ devant monk adjoumani et ses
mariages sauter officer de mondanités la
pa croissant et
[Musique]
selon lui
vous avez lu le journal
non pourquoi
s'est suicidé
allez
sans quoi ils pourraient quand même
temps partir plus tôt
non
c'est qu'une pomme
ce sont des gens comme vous ma famille
vous avez traité deux mois
maintenant gentil ouest
tout cela ajouté t-elle pandémie
pourquoi tant de haine et de jugement
dans ce moment chaque personne a le
droit de vivre sa vie comme il veut un
pur navet qui mêla montant s'est dé
nouveau avec un pc
[Musique]
donc nous allons maintenant procéder à
votre union comme monsieur du cheval
je n'y consentez vous à prendre pour
époux monsieur payet je l'attends oui je
le veux
[Musique]
qu'en pensez-vous qu'en savez-vous à
prendre pour époux monsieur du chemin où
mes cheveux
d'après aux réponses séparé est
affirmative au nom de la loi
je vous déclare unis par le mariage
nous allons maintenant considérer les
changes
[Musique]
bonjour
m
[Applaudissements]
nous avons assez
[Musique]
on dit que les mots
tu es une histoire c'est un amour que
j'espérais vivre avec toi d'autres fois
on était si heureux
et j'aurais tout fait pour toi fonder
une famille par l'adoption était notre
premier choix
je savais qu aux yeux des gens on est
assez différent je me disais que c'était
moi ils ne sont pas si méchants
je continue à croire en eux malgré tout
les jugements je voulais te devra malgré
tout et pourtant ils nous font de la
peine lors jacobsen j'aimerais te main
qui me coupe
atelier d'exister
ne peuvent être critiqués se faire enfin
accepté
la tristesse la chauffeuse me résous de
ta vie le regard des gens tu as beaucoup
fait souffrir
je ne sais pas pour boire je suis a
préféré partir je n'ai pas su avoir
et de vous tenir
même si on fait partie de ma vie que
dire que faire
face à tant de mépris je ne comprends
pas ton corps
c'est mon ego
l'univers de la peine
pour jeter
j'aimerais tellement qui nous coupe
l élite
exister
ne peut être critiqué
l'europe c'est tôt
[Musique]
à